Tổng thống Mỹ đường nơi trang cho biết, này 1 tháng 6 ông đã có khu định đàn với tổng thống na,
là đi mì poch in để chào đổi vị tình hình chính xử.
Đó biệt là loa tập kích măng tích bị bài không người lấy.
Nhà mở nhiều cân cụ không quân nè, con được uống quân nè gọi là chính dịch mạnh nền.
Pù cho đổi kếm sài một dờ mời phút được ông trò mùa tà là tốt đẹp.
Nhưng không để giận tới hòa bình nè lập tức.
Tổng thống poch in đã chia sẻ chỉ tiếp kết quả vòng đầm phán thứ 2,
giữa ngá bởi quân nè tại xa quân ngày 1,5,
ông cá bụt uống quân nè của tình phá ngoại tính chính đối thoại.
Bằng việc tấn công các một tư dân sự,
gọi các vụ phá ngoại đường xát tại branch và khớt,
là hành động khuộc bố từ việc quân nè,
đông thơ khẩn định mắt sở cơ vã sệ có phản đứng cương dân.
Cô định đàn được tự kiện sau khi cả Washington và Mắt sở bà thống nếu sang,
tấn đối thoại tất cả ông trường quốc cạnh liều thăng tháng tháng mới.
Trời đó, đặc phải viên về suốt đủ quân nè của tổng thống Mình Dunan Trump,
ông khíc theo ló nghe một bà thằng sau nhận định,
của tập kế của uống quân nè, kiến suổi gói lâm tháng từ mức không thể chấp nhận.
Giờ trên dựa liệu ngồi mở tình đến hết nhi một bà thằng sau,
đong tấn công của quân nè trong chính sĩnh mặt nền,
nhằm vào các cân cứu chính lửa của nha đã pháu ý nhất mới là mấy bài chiến đấu các loại.
Tất cả điều hài cân cứu tại Muman's và E-Cross,
mụ quân phòng ra cũng sâm nhận các cờ bị tập tất kế một số viết cơ bốc trái.